Speaker 1: Let's try Josiah from North
Carolina. Josiah, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: What's going on, Deepak? How are
you doing? Well. So obviously, big news from
Wisconsin. You heard that Republicans in
Wisconsin are already at least a few of
them talking about impeaching Justice Protasevich.
Speaker 1: I did not hear that. For what reason?
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, right now they're just
kind of forecasting it. They would come up with
grounds that she's not going to are not going
to abide by her oath. She's not going to support
Wisconsin law. Right. And the idea is just,
you know, throw anything at or that sticks.
Would you be surprised if they do that.
Speaker 1: If they actually impeach her
or if they try to.
Speaker 2: Pry, too?
Speaker 1: Oh, no, it would not surprise me. But,
you know, oftentimes it's sort of like Marjorie
Taylor GREENE has tried to impeach Joe Biden,
but it doesn't even get started. So,
you know, the word try is doing a lot of
heavy work there. You know what I mean?
Speaker 2: The the bulk of my question
concerns actually my state, North Carolina. I
don't know if you heard this, but one of our
state representatives, her name is Tricia Latham.
Just this morning, she formally announced that
she was switching from the Democratic Party to
the Republican Party, even though she ran as a
Democrat in November and was just sworn in
in January the first. My first question is,
do you consider this fraudulent? Well.
Speaker 1: So I think the problem with
fraudulent or unethical is can you prove that
this was her intent at the time? Obviously, you're
allowed to switch party, but if there was, I think
in order to demonstrate that it's fraudulent, you
would have to demonstrate that this was part of a
plan all the way from the beginning. I don't know
whether you can demonstrate that or not. If you
could, I think it would certainly be fraudulent.
Speaker 2: That's fair. That's fair. And
certainly I agree to like a legal scrutiny.
I would not I would make the case that there's a
compelling case to be made that you could prove
it to a legal satisfaction. But, yeah, I guess
she you know, she ran as a progressive Democrat
in Mecklenburg County, which is a really blue
district of North Carolina. It's just right up.
It's part of Charlotte. Yeah. And it seems to me
pretty sketch that in three months she's switching
party switching platforms and there's no run off a
recall like provision there. Would you support in
the event that a politician switches parties and
switches platforms and things like that, that it
triggers some sort of recall or run off provision?
Speaker 1: That's really tough. I, I would I'm
open to voters deciding whether they want a
recall. I don't know about automatically doing
it. And here's the difficulty. People do change
positions during the time that they're in office.
So then you would have to say, well, if you
change positions enough or if you change party,
my view is you, the voters should be able to
gather signatures if they want to recall someone,
but it ultimately has to be up to the voters.
I'm not going to say anytime you change party,
you should be immediately. There should be
a recall election that seems like too much,
but you should be subject to a recall.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess it's it's kind of it's
the reason I'm so salty about it is because her
doing so has given Republicans and North Carolina
a veto proof majority. We were one seat away from
it. And Governor Cooper was kind of you know,
he's a Democrat and he was getting by by the skin
of his teeth. And now that she's switched parties,
it's a it's a veto proof majority.
Speaker 1: It's ugly. It's ugly,
No doubt. I understand that. And I mean, listen,
the voters can consider that in determining
whether they would want to have a recall election.
Speaker 2: No. Yeah, I agree. As far as I know,
I don't think that it even allows like a recall
election. I agree that you're probably right that
an auto recall is probably too cumbersome, but
there are at least should be a provision that
if if enough of her constituents like it. I
think in the event of George Santos. Right.
The guy, the serial liar out of North Carolina.
Speaker 1: 80% of New York, New York, New York.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah. Sorry. A North Carolina
brand at the moment. But yeah, New York,
80% of his constituents want him to resign.
Right. And as far as I know, there's no recall
provision there. Like even if enough of his
constituents demand his resignation, he's he's
allowed to serve the remainder of his term.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Not every place has recall
provisions, but very, very interesting
situation there in North Carolina. I
appreciate you telling us about it.
Speaker 2: I appreciate that,
David. Have a good one.
Speaker 1: All right.
There goes Josiah. And that'll do it for
calls today. We'll take a quick break and
then get to your emails and your tweets
and your comments and the entire thing